these are two of the most recognizable
photos from World War two the one on the
left is raising the flag on Iwo Jima by
Joe Rosenthal
it shows US Marines raising the American
flag on top of Mount Suribachi following
the Battle of Iwo Jima in Japan the one
on the right is raising a flag over the
reichstag by yevgeny cloudy it shows a
young russian soldier planting the
Soviet flag on the roof of the former
German parliament building it was taken
in the heart of burned-out Berlin after
Russians captured the city and the Nazis
were ultimately defeated the two photos
are similar they're both huge symbols of
victory for their respective countries
and they're both taken after the fights
were over when the armies lifted larger
flags to replace the smaller ones raised
during battle but the Russian one is
different for one it's staged unlike
Rosenthal's candid snapshot cal DS is
carefully posed plus parts of it were
altered before it was published this is
the photo that became iconic and this is
the original see the difference
call the superimposed some black smoke
from another photo and manipulated the
contrast to give the scene a little more
drama but there's something else and you
have to look really close or you might
miss it see it yet it's right here what
happened to this guy's watch
Hitler's invasion of Russia in June 1941
codenamed Operation Barbarossa was
ruthless and prolonged and ended in
millions of Russians being killed
including women and children the German
army committed brutal atrocities
including burnings rape and sanctioned
mass murder of civilians they weren't
soldiers and they weren't killed in back
mass murder by orders of the High
Command the bodies of hundreds of
civilians were found in an anti-tank
ditch people who had been slaughtered on
mass by the execution squads so when the
tide of the war changed in the Russians
favor in 1942 they saw an opportunity
for revenge in the Russians final
onslaught against Germany in April 1945
Stalin ordered his marshals to race to
Berlin at all cost
even though he committed to sharing the
capital cities capture with his allies
this recklessness resulted in needlessly
high casualties for the Russians in some
instances from bombarding their own army
amid all the confusion the Red Army
stormed across Eastern Europe and just
like the Germans had done committed
civilian murder burnings mass rapes and
looting acts that they saw as vengeance
for their countrymen and acts that go
largely undiscussed in Russia to this
day which brings us back to Col deze
photo an iconic victory photo would have
been a boon for Soviet public image
around the world and Soviet officials
possibly even Stalin himself wanted it
to be in Berlin it would be their answer
to Rosenthal's in wajima photo which had
published a few months earlier and
became a beloved symbol of American
triumph the image even appeared on this
propaganda poster which helped raise
over 26 billion dollars for the American
war effort in 1945 so after the fighting
in Berlin had ended call D was flown in
from Moscow with his camera and an
enormous Soviet flag sewn from three
tablecloths he gathered a couple of
nearby soldiers to pose on the right
stacks roof and shot a full roll of 36
photos ultimately choosing this one but
there was a problem the soldier
supporting the flag bearer was wearing
two watches suggesting he had been
looting a stain that didn't fit the
image of Soviet heroism that Stalin
so-called II scratched it out with a
needle and this was how it appeared when
it first published in a popular Russian
magazine a week and a half later this
historic moment on top of the Reichstag
is actually reimagined in the 2015 movie
child 44 the facts are exaggerated but
the reference is clear whose the garden
watches well take them off stolen
watches they can't be seen this photo
shows a lot of things it shows a
reenactment of a historic moment on top
of the Reichstag the symbolic seat of
German power they represents triumph and
pride the Soviet victory over their
fascist invaders after a hard-fought and
bloody war but unintentionally it also
captures and then conceals a story of
vengeance and mutual brutality of murder
organized destruction and pillaging all
culminating in this iconic moment
[Music]
there's some speculation that what was
edited out of this photo wasn't a second
watch but actually a wrist worn compass
it was called the adrionna compass and
it was widely used by the Soviet Army
but if that's all it was
why they scratch it out